老子你每次講最厲害的籌碼就是關鍵分點
今天大放鬆了
關鍵分點呢我們有幾個SOP
哇這分點都是厲害的
現賺五萬塊一張
對
Special的
Special
好
這個是我今年給你的禮物
喔全台灣好不好
1700檔公司的關鍵分點
直接告訴你答案
直接告訴我
對 紅馬K線這個軟體
這邊都看得很清楚
有很多人說
小哥最近太早來理台大安秀
太早來 太忙了
太忙
可是我看你都在PO吃喝玩熱啊
然後你體重你都沒有瘦
欸欸欸
因為呢
我都去各地上課
你是去上課嗎
對
我看你一下去宜蘭
一下去花蓮
一下去台南
對啊 宜蘭花園比較少上課
是真的去玩
不過台南 高雄 嘉義 彰化 台中 新竹 桃園 台北
西岸就對了
西岸都在上課
學員太多了
學員太多 多少
大概一萬多人有啦
我的學員因為貴節目
增加很多
理財達人秀歌有仇必報
大家看了歌有仇必報之後
覺得這個看得還不過癮
所以今天大放送
講一個非常禁忌的話題
真的是禁忌喔
真的特別的
特別的
好
哇 大家有沒有超期待
歌有仇必報
跟趙華做到第19集了
我跟你講喔
小哥的太太喔
注意囉
你一定覺得
趙華最近都沒在撩
對不對
因為趙華做電視節目
做得好累喔
但是小哥今天被我逮到了
我們這一集非常的禁忌
非常的禁忌
怎麼禁忌法呢
大家以前都會敲碗說
小哥你每次講最厲害的籌碼
就是關鍵分點
可惜關鍵分點不能說
今天好不好
這一集拜託你回去看100遍
關鍵分點
我們今天把小哥壓榨出來了
把它榨乾了
因為呢
對跟趙華做了19次
總要交出點貨來
沒問題
沒問題對不對
還記得我們上一集
我們有個截圖嗎
什麼截圖
我知道
你記得去我的FB看一下
該你的老二表現一下
該我的老二表現一下
前面是說那老大表現得很好啊
老大華邦店啊
我就是說交加的老二要表現一下
交加老二關我什麼事啊
我不曉得為什麼這個理財達人秀的字幕好像
這寫起來好像蠻奇怪的
該我的老二表現一下
這個我覺得把它截圖
蠻好玩的
放在粉絲團上很多讚
對比過去報的名牌準
它還更多讚
因為剛好隔天就噴了
隔天噴了 老二表現了
你家說老二噴了
今天老三噴了
今天是老三噴
今天是華新客長
我們來看我們最近講的標的
最近講的標的
其實我們不是投顧老師
我們不是投顧老師
當然不是
我們不能代單
我們是教學節目
教你方法
我們從來不代單
这都是他们自己人品好
他们学会了
他们学会自己人品好
他们自己去研究筹码
我们会跟他们讲说
这个股票像华邦店
你就要特别注意管钱的分点
这个其实公开
我们在理财大人秀
也有教大家
讲很多次了
很难得
很难得愿意讲关键分点在哪里
因为管钱分点那很大
跟学员讲
学员有正续研究
小哥说的是对的
而且買很多喔
所以他們就去買
因為他們就跟著關鍵分點做
那一買之後
他們就加薪了
像這個學院賺了24萬
因為它有35口的
華邦店期貨
各股期
這個學院賺了12萬
這個學院買一堆
真的很巧
跟達人秀做集團股交加做账
差不多時間
因為它大概10月多就買了
所以他們很多人都抱一個波段
那抱一個波段呢
再利用期貨槓桿的特性
其實他們用很多人都用小錢賺了大錢
而且上次華邦店其實有說
關鍵分點因為很早就佈局了
所以我們節目播的時候
他有一點點在逢高貨率出脫
但接下來還是連續大漲了兩三天
因為火車開動之後很難停下來
華邦店是火車啊
那很大股本啊
那這個它在上面稍微調節
我剛剛看了一下
華邦店的這關鍵分點
其實囤貨還是囤很多
稍微慢一點而已
稍微慢一點而已喔
而且這樣繼續往上拉
而它的個股其實好處就是
它可以快速的
也是快速進出啊
而且它的量很大
這個期貨的華旺店
我們有的期貨還怕流動性風險
那華旺店沒有
華旺店沒有
當然它大股本的公司全基股啊
那他們就花個幾千塊
就可以買個一口
那就慢慢的
這個我看到這種
對啊,我們都替他們開心
對啊,好厲害,學得很好
這些都是靠他們自己去研究分點
你看南亞科也是喔
南亞科關鍵分點也是大買
這個我們在交易筆記本上面
也提過很多啦
對,但是我也必須講啦
因為很多人看理財達人秀
他會很困擾一件事情
小哥都秀的關鍵分點啊
第一,我哪知道誰是關鍵分點
第二,我哪怎麼統計關鍵分點
小哥是沒講到我的股票
我就不知道了
所以他們需要的是工具
對 然後所以呢你知道
每次我們節目一播出下面就說
小哥你幫我看這一家關鍵分點
小哥你幫我看這個B股票的關鍵分點
沒辦法這樣應付 因為這是要自己學的
而且也不能公開啦
有些公開之後他就真的搬家了
可是今天不行
今天會公開一些
然後再來就是現在這個時間點
因為我們節目公開也講過嘛
就是說年底
其實是作帳最強的時刻
我們如果不撈這一波
真的是很可惜
對 很可惜
每年12月最好賺
而且搞不好比那種
3月19號上來都還好賺
對 這裡都噴翻了
什麼聯電 華邦電
這以前都是很牛的股票
長榮 哇 那麼牛
我們叫王寶川股嘛
苦手含咬18年才這樣
對 這些都非常強
那為什麼年底最好賺呢
給各位看一下
第一個 集團作帳
對啊 真的 焦師傅
焦師傅
真的厲害
所以很多个师傅都很厉害
连郭师傅都可以长
郭师傅 黄师傅 焦师傅 陈师傅
好几个师傅都很厉害
大家自己对话入座
第二个财报空窗
对 已经进入空窗期了
明年三月我才知道
对啊 我现在要怎么喊都可以
好坏喔
现在都不用负责任的
不负责任
第三个我们最近发现
很多关键分点都大买
你的意思是本来可能10月11月还好
12月了一堆关键分点觉得
哎呀该我表现啦
对啊
所以关键分点在12月很活络
很活络
局来说
来吧我们来看这个
焦师傅的
这个你有透露过
因为他们的媳妇
媳妇有元大的人嘛
对元大的人
送分题嘛
哇我们今天这个把两个都合在一起
它就是关键分点啦
好
同一个分点埋在前面
我們來看像這個同一個管錢分點
華新啊
各位看到他買在這裡
好
後面噴出喔
華新
這大牛股喔
不鏽鋼股
對 那這個華幫店買在這邊
這就厲害了
之後是1000張1000張買喔
這天是2萬張
後面噴出喔
彩晶呢
他買在這裡
後面就馬上噴出喔
彩晶他算很有毅力的喔
面板股其實他的籌碼
現在看起來最厲害了
沒錯沒錯
所以這個我們之前有講過
有娶了元大的媳妇
也懶得換地方了
就在車水馬龍的管前
東森的旁邊
所以他的關鍵分點就是
元差管前
好
沒問題
不要答錯答案了
我猜焦師傅也不會再搬家了
不會啦
又不會換媳婦
這不一定
但是做了那麼多年都在這裡
可信度很高
而且他不怕你知道
對
對啊
讓你知道又怎麼樣
我們就是要做啊
全世界都知道我教師傅會集團做這個
對啊,不然要這樣做
對啊
請教師傅來上電視好了
對,好
那這些呢
其實我們利用這個
筹码K線裡面
對
手機板
手機板就有了嗎
對
我們今天特別來看這個手機板
哇,今天華心科
因為這個就是剛剛趙華講的啦
關鍵分點
其實如果你沒有任何的軟體
坦白說撈不出來
對
坦白說不知道
所以趙華必須講
有時候小哥講的東西
你也沒有辦法等嘛
你手上1700多檔股票
你要自己做功課說實話沒有軟體做不到對這個坦白說所以現在手機有個APP就對了手機APP這是籌碼K線的APP籌碼K線小哥其實一直都是用籌碼K線
很好用啊
目前台灣在做籌碼上面
這個公司算是最厲害的
我們來看像華邦店
華邦店我們看他的籌碼
籌碼日報
例如說我看這60天來
60天來我們剛剛講的那個管錢
元大管前他買了三萬一千多張
雖然他有做稍微調節一點
小賣一點
不過這台車已經被他開動了
不容易停下來
所以千萬不要去放空
沒坐多到不要去空
沒搭上車就算了 不要放空
除了滑膀店以外
像最近這個彩晶
彩晶我們剛剛也有講
彩晶的關鍵分點
管前哥
他也是買在這個地方
所以这个都看得很清楚
那这60天来可以看得到
管钱哥买了三万三千多张
都是管钱哥做的啊
对 做得很好
就是说焦是不是很坦荡荡
没错
我们在做筹码的时候
我们都是从
看看最近有没有主力连买的标的来找
那可以从这边的选股可以找到
选股这边呢
各位您选官方
官方这里有多方
多方这里呢
像這邊可以選主力連買
OK
主力連買我們可以看到
最近第一名是凱聖
這凱聖是因為被收購了
主力買了一定賺錢
所以主力買了80天
第二名就是最近很強的
南亞科
我跟你講南亞科也很神奇
雖然這邊不該提另外一個人
古玉也剛好南亞科
你記得嗎 在節目上
因為他有基本面的支撐
他也有籌碼面的加持
南亞科我們看他的籌碼
我們看他的籌碼
这60天奶里面呢
大买
那其中第一名
檀摩跟史丹尼
大摩
不过大摩它不是关键分点
第二名就是关键分点
所以这是外资加上
我们的关键分点
双加持
对
所以今天特别透露第二名的关键分点
因为大摩蛮正常
因为那两个有算全职股
看好记忆体就买
好
那这第二名关键分点给各位看一下
它就是负差
各位看一下
画面看得到
它低档就买很多了
负邦
把他讲出来了
我认得字
我只是照念而已
最近
其实它最近涨上来还继续买
所以看起来记忆体真的很缺
对
很缺
这真的很缺
那么从这筹码可以看得出来
那这个选股呢
不只可以选多方
像多方里面主力连买可以选
还有外资连买
投信连买
Top 1的券商买超异常
那空方呢
各位看一下空方
空方有这个主力联卖的
我们来看一下
最近主力联卖
哇 结态
等于是说我不放空
我也别碰它了
对不对
可能走时会问题
结态卖了37天
哇 这看起来好恐怖
见准卖34天
这边都看得很清楚
好 但是重点在
刚刚讲了
不见得买最多的会是关键分点
有可能是外资
有可能投信
也不见得买最多的分点
就叫做关键分点
因为它叫关键嘛
那它一定是过去
每一次都非常厉害
它才能叫关键
它只是刚好督到啊
或刚好跟单啊
那我们不算对不对
我觉得这太难了
我哪知道
所以我们关键分点呢
我们有几个SOP
SOP找出真正的关键分点
对不对
好看第一个呢
我们会找寻高档大卖的分点
就很厉害
抓到高點賣出
對 高檔要賣出
而且要賣很多張喔
你賣個一張
那你運氣好
對不對
我們找的都是賣
不會啊 國巨如果賣在
國巨賣在1300
那個一張
我也是覺得很配付
一張
我追蹤你好累喔
不知道你什麼時候才要再買
我們追蹤的都是買幾萬張
賣幾萬張的
OK
好 第二個呢
第一檔大買的分點
然後第三呢
我們在找獲利的分點
那通常呢
高檔有大賣 低檔有大賣
它就很容易是獲利的分店
好 因為它都已經做那麼標準了
它一定會賺錢的啊
對 而且賺很多喔
好 那第四個呢
關鍵分點我們常常發現
它是地緣分點
剛剛就有講
我才會問你 是不是在新竹啊
對 鹿港啊
鹿港啊 台南啊
甜甜架啊 你還記得
我們那時候講甜甜架嘛
記得啊 可憲啊
噴出了 也噴了
應該來得及啦 沒有碰很多
從他之前的戰績來看
應該還來得及
第五個 同級船 常常就相同分點
像剛剛講的 交師傅
交師傅的 管錢分點
也不想換了
做給你看 這真的很棒
好 所以這是SOP
我們利用關鍵分點的找法
我們來看一下 關鍵分點怎麼找
好 第一個 台南人來了
高檔大賣 有沒有
真的賣超多耶 這怎麼回事
有
像瀑布一樣
對啊 低檔大賣 有沒有
有喔 有喔
沙滴 今年年初三月份的時候
我們最近找關鍵分店 有時候都會找
3月19號你敢大買的
你就是關鍵分店 我覺得他厲害在
他這波還賣滿兇
他先買 可能知道要盤整
他就慢慢買耶
慢慢買 要不急咧
那急煞都大買喔
急殺 你看上次的低點急殺又大買
這個應該就是他那時候場賣掉
大家覺得沒搞頭了
對 那時候外資狂砍
對 通通接走
對 通通接走 你看在這個點也
低一點 大買 那時候一百七十幾塊
其實如果你用可成這個線來看
這邊不算貴耶 對不對
因為他這邊就買了耶
便宜啊 我待會再給你看一個東西
甜甜價
再給你看一個東西你就知道這個價格
其實看起來還不算貴
哎呀 這不就我們的節目嗎
來吧 歌友手臂爆
李兆华跟全鎮小哥
第17集
纠葛
到现在才第19集而已
这段时间你跑去哪
我没有
这段时间我们都在做电视版
然后你都跑去游山玩水教学员
教学
好
这就像您讲的
这一档Gender要听台南人的
那时候你已经买70几块
各位看一下股价在这里
真的耶
那时候我们讲这个台南人大买
对
那时候台南人大买
然后各位看一下
这个台南人呢
我给各位看一个东西
痛载八国联军
对 我给各位看呢
这个资料是十年的资料
2011年啊
对
一直到今年
因为有筹码显示
是从2011年才开始
所以有筹码以来
有筹码以来
所有的资料都在这里
所有资料在这边
OK
那这个里面呢
最厉害的分点叫
XX北高雄
靠近台南
北高雄就靠近台南
对对对 没错
对
插北高雄
各位看一下
他买均价是209.86
那我现在买跟他差不多而已
差不多
他卖均价260.69
现赚5万块一张
对
而且他是买几张
买3万多张
买3万7万5万2
厉害哦
对啊
而且这中间还有佩席
对对对
好歹可曾是有赚钱的公司
配期都没有算进去
那这个台南人
这个北高雄这个分点
光可曾这十年来赚了28亿
28亿
叔叔我不想努力了
找一下
我们要找一下台南的阿姨
对
阿姨我也不喜欢努力
对 我不想努力了
台南人我不想努力了
快把我带回去
好 那我看一下
这个北高雄是第二名
我们再看底下分点
因为这有些分点
它已经都消失了
底下分点
第四名XX台南
第五名XX台南
第六名XX东门
这东门是台北东门还是台南的东门
这台南东门
X金华
XX永康
永康也台南啊
XX金鼎台南
大家都知道
大家都知道是哪个台南
反正呢
台南人啊
我跟你讲台南人最好待的公司就是可城
以后小朋友栽培他
我跟他说
以后你要记得
你要去可乘上班
去可乘上班要干嘛
打好关系
然后看清楚在哪个分点
开个户
然后也巴结一下营业园
反正里面
反正台南分点
这些人我们可以都知道
你一定是一堆员工在里面
我是听说这样子
是听说轩跟我讲
他说他们主委跟他讲
最近趕快買 趕快買
所以最近都是台南人在買
我們老闆也叫我趕快買房子
也沒錯 也沒錯
今年房地產很強 對你看這台南人算一算加起來賺 我們這樣算台南人賺可乘這10年來賺超過100億用可乘在股市提款100億
沒錯 我還沒有算股息喔
還沒有算喔
陳真可乘的高層男友好不好
比較快
可能會在北高雄開戶的那個人
好 所以這邊你有把剛剛講的公布對不對
XX是什麼
XX
不小心了
這邊忘了遮
可塵在這邊
對
你看厲害的分點在這裡
還有這個X比高雄
好
哇
這分點都是厲害的
這邊都有名字了
然後大家自己看
自己截圖
自己看
對 我們就不念了
但是趙華還是不知道啊
我要怎麼統計出來
用手撈嘛
當然
太辛苦了吧
你要利用籌碼
K線這個軟體
所以剛剛有提到
还是要软体工具
因为其实筹码是很麻烦的
筹码是2011年才公布在网站上
让人家捞
所以我也可以手动统计
我可以做一万张的Excel表
然后就累死我自己
统计不出来
太难了
所以台南人帮大家赚大钱
我们跟着做就好啦
也不用真的成真什么男友了
其实看理财答案秀就够了
就够了
那我这边先贴的是我的对账单
你的对账单
这是我的
不好意思 赵阿常常收到
赵阿常常收到小哥的对账单
我真的很想显示你的财力
让我觉得很迷恋你
不是 我跟你讲说
我们研究筹码是对的
是
我们后面会有对账单来
犒赏我们
你干对了
你跟着谈人做得很漂亮
所以不要送什么鲜花
也不要送什么名牌包
送对账单
送我一口吗
喂我一口
喂你一口
我们现在讲可诚
可能对象但是我们是这样子
我有把它分散
因为这个避免同一个户头口数太多
万一大跌的时候不好砍
所以把它分散一下
那分散呢各位看一下
这是我把它分散成三个户头
那这户头呢20口均价189
小柯你怎么均价那么高
还记得我们是170几讲的吗
对
因为呢这是12月份的期货
12月咯
其实我们从9月就讲了
对 我们从9月10月11月一直转仓过来
哦 那么久
对 每个月转仓的时候
已经有以食线损益了
那以食线损益我们都不大想去看它
因为这个热热等
所以今天只放了这个一个户头的以食线
这个不小心空了紧说赔了10万
不要看不要看
赔钱也贴啦
总不能说这个只讲赚钱
那可乘 因为这户头比较干净
这不小心空到井
不小心用这户头空
应该这户头里面只放可乘而已
那可乘光转仓就赚了38万
那这三个户头各位看
这未时间损益今天截除下来
都非常漂亮
其实很多人都说
赵华主持这个理财大人秀
尤其是哥有丑必报
应该自己也赚很多
其实也是有啦
但是我还没有进入到软体的阶段
因為我都聽你說就好了
直接告訴你答案
直接告訴我
那這些不止可乘
像我們之前講的
夜輝
你看這我就聽你講的
還記得這一集嗎
記得
我記得你有因為這檔而幫自己加薪
你看看這是我的手
這是你的手
是不是很有一種戀愛Fu
對啊一起畫一個心
對畫一個心有沒有
當時我有夜輝
你有夜輝
心心相應
新相應
應該賺滿多的
對
那時候講說
這個大戶增加散戶減
股價未反應
獨立買超
大戶持股比喻增加
散戶持股比喻下降
那時候才7塊多
這個都在軟體都看得到
是
對啊
你看到股價跌下來
主力都沒跑
就不用怕了
對
而且他們真的是低檔
7塊多
不要怕
現在都已經佔回票面
10塊多以上了
你看現在多少
不只佔回票面
因為我照法後來賣掉
最高點12塊
7块到12块
对啊
我就说7块也pass吧
这个六七成的获利
对啊
非常惊人
叶辉耶
钢铁骨耶
我不是跟你讲小型的腰骨耶
我们讲钢铁骨的时候
收视率跌到骨顶
对啊
这个莫然回首一看
哇塞
长六七成
对 长那么多
那这些分点
我们证交所得正
其实真的是得正
以前我们要到
这样要透露年龄了
南海路那里嘛
哪路啊
還要進去裡面的圖書館
還要翻東西嗎
我是聽人家講的啦
翻老半天
你聽老一輩講的嘛
對 我聽老一輩講的
我也聽老一輩有講過
我還沒去過啊
好 現在正教授
你在家裡
這個輸入網址啊
這個還要輸入這個
看不太清楚的辨識碼
去辨識碼 這很煩耶
我常常會輸入錯誤
對 很過分
不曉得是1還是i
而且有些人還要規定
你大小寫要對
那更讓我抓狂
好累好累
輸入完之後呢
它會給你一串熱熱等的
這個資料
圖表
自己要匯出
做Excel表
對
那每天做這個
太累了
光益黨股票
就61額
我怎麼做
對
對啊
61額太累了
所以我們都會利用
這個籌碼K軟體來看
可是剛剛講籌碼K軟體
如果用手機APP來看
它有局限性
它沒有辦法撈很長的歷史資料
因為你剛剛講說
關鍵分點有時候
我們要觀察10年
2011年公布它要常常準
手機才240天
如果它是最近一年準
最近一年誰不準
最近一年很多散戶也很準
那些大家都鼓神了
所以我要怎麼做
就是我要怎樣才能撈到更長的資料
來確認它叫關鍵分點
好
這裡呢
我們就用電腦來顯示一下
小哥的日常
快給我一杯咖啡
我要來看小哥選鼓囉
例如說可成
這10年來
大家真的要珍惜耶
小哥現在在教大家懸鼓
來 這10年來很簡單
我們用2500天
一年250天就超過了
你都是幾點懸鼓
幾點懸鼓 晚上6、7、8點
那麼早啊
應該可以演一下
例如在睡前啊
睡前
就說小哥你在幹嘛
來我幫你按摩你在幹嘛
睡前的按摩
我要找明天的標的啊
明天送我的東西上
對對對 好
那這個可誠呢
找關鍵分點教你找一下
2500天
這個點下去
點下去之後呢
我們再來看一個東西
看區間獲利
2500天就是所有資料對不對
對所有資料
區間獲利點出來
我們剛剛講的
哇北高雄啊
台南啊
台南東門金華
剛剛的那張圖
永康台南
對都出來了
其實就是剛剛那張圖
對
而且他們今天應該賺更多了
因為今天股價又噴出去
今天我都沒跟到
哎呀可惜啊
那這個看起來
今天是主力買上軌翹喔
所以還來得及對不對
還來得及啊
剛剛才開始而已
好啦 那小哥你送我一口嗎
送你一口
送你一個可承
好的 好 那可能關鍵分點
關鍵分點就這樣找
那這軟體呢
這個你可以看主力買超
最近主力轉買超了
那外資剛好現在這個籌碼出來
外資呢大買
外資大買
你就可以點了 例如說你點這個
北高雄 哇 他是買了這個點的
好厲害喔 它是點很漂亮啊
那這張避險這邊也會顯示
那這邊呢 你還可以看什麼東西啊
你可以看技術指標啊 KD MACD RSI
這邊都可以看 也很方便啊
誰要看技術指標 不用了
有的人喜歡看 RSI 不用了 不用了
那你可以看內部人的持有比率啊
不過你記得看這個
這個是幾%
這8.4、8.5、8.6、8.7
這沒有差多少
沒關係
那最近可乘的大戶
各位看一下
大戶慢慢上來囉
是
散戶慢慢掉下來了
這叫做健康
它叫做健康
因為散戶離開了嘛
這個股票上漲
理論上大戶要繼續買
沒錯
散戶要獲利了結
那這個健康的
假如股票漲上來
散戶來追
對
這叫做信仰
代表有人鼓吹
不過今年有一段時間散戶是厲害的
但現在其實又匯到了內資盤
還是要看這些大戶
因為我們很怕股票
在高檔的時候散戶去追
那種後面都容易跌下來
那這裡你也可以看融資融捐
哇 可成融資在減喔
那這個可成的借券也在變少
券資比是往下
它是券資都往下
可是這時候是不是應該希望放空它人變多呢
還可以再嘎一下
可能大家都看我們節目啦
我們節目出事宜太高了誰敢空啊好那就不管他了對均值比高你可以看一些比較特別的股票我最喜歡看籌碼
最喜歡看這個主力買超
主力買散戶賣幾保戶數
看這三個指標
最近有一檔股票
瞬間跌很慘喔
來看玉鼎
這一瞬間的喔
這線圖好不正常
不是跳空漲停就是跳空跌停
在左邊的討論區有人鼓吹人家買
那人一買之後一追
各位看一追上來是主力到貨喔
好誇張
主力到貨然後呢這個散戶大買
幾百戶數從12000變成16000
都散戶再買
都散戶再上去了
那散戶呢這個上去之後
這個他就容易崩盤
崩下來
那這檔更誇張的喔
各位你看這邊有個重大事件
中央事件这边有个申报转让
申报转让你看
在高档12月1号
12月1号
这个法恩董事申报1952张
董监事的申报转让也是一个指标
没错
那申报投资申报1500张
在高档
你看到董事
这法恩在卖了
主力又在卖
赶快跑快逃
董事在卖我们就要董事了
知道发生事情了
没错
可以从这边看
好 所以這就是剛剛小哥用電腦的軟體
因為電腦可以看過去十年的走勢
所以籌碼上面到底誰厲害
過去十年誰厲害全部都列出來
小哥有教我們怎麼找
但是你知道
哥 我不想努力了
你不想努力了
我也不想找
那我把我的
這個今天要送給你的
為什麼今天有禮物
有禮物啦
這代表我對你的愛心
因為耶誕節要到對不對
而且聽說你的生日快到了
喔 12月是兆華月
兆華月要過生日
又有耶誕節
又要跨年
所以你是要約我跨年嗎
啊 約跨年
今年還有跨年
今天有跨年
對啊 我沒有幫你抽個號碼牌
現在就是第237號
還好還好 今年行情沒有很熱
好 對好
好 這個是我今年給你的禮物
什麼禮物
很厚的喔
對
你可以摸看看
我摸看看
我可以摸看看是不是
哇 我可以摸看看
割給我的東西
這個一點點厚厚的
等等等等
房地器嗎
對對對 你打開就知道了
Oh my god
是
全台灣好不好
1700檔公司的關鍵分點
關鍵分點
全部都在上面
我們只找了325檔
什麼東西
為什麼不是1700檔
因為有的股票很小啊
很小就沒有關鍵分點
大家想知道嗎
所以我們做股票呢
看這分點就可以了
對 看這分點
有大買大賣
可是我現在知道分點了
我還是要搭配你的籌碼K啊
對 搭配籌碼K啊
那你就每天幫我看一下
沒問題啊
我們有這個LINE
對 好但是呢
不是每個人都跟趙華一樣有這個福利喔
因為趙華也做了19次
才拿到
那你平常沒有辦法跟小哥在一起怎麼辦呢
研究一下啦 籌碼K
其實趙華知道這個軟體很久了
沒想到小哥願意今天來全部全都講喔
裡面關鍵分點資料就是
過去十年全部厲害關鍵分點都在裡面
對
我們今天特別
各位呢
你假如有買籌碼K的話
買電腦版
我們會送手機版
就剛剛講那個app裡面
有一些還是要付費的功能
它就可以去解鎖
可以解鎖
一天不到22塊
那我可以免費拿嗎
沒有問題
待會請小秘書給你一個免費的
那我們這個
贈送325家
第一买高卖
关键分点的清单
就在这里面
有送这个吗
这个你什么时候
才要达成你的承诺
你要变这样啊
你说变瘦吗
对啊
这都靠修土的
所以我们后置
帮小哥脸下修瘦
好不好
叮
这样子
好的
好
所以最后呢
我看一下
最后我们教各位
好
这很多人都问说
那小哥关键分点买
那我就要买吗
不是这样吗
不是哦
为什么
我们桌单
為什麼不
因為呢
你進場的時候
可能外資還在到貨啊
因為關鍵分點
通常都買在外資到貨的時候
其實我聽過一個說法
因為關鍵分點本身是大股東或大戶嘛
所以它有能力一直收一直收
也可能收很久
也可能收很多
但我們這種小蝦米
我們要買在最精準的位置
對不對
我要買在發動點
對啊
我哪有辦法像它這樣一收幾個月
我反而都煩死了
對
所以我們這個進場點教你
關鍵買的時候你先觀察
我先觀察
你得看到主力買的時候你就進場
主力就是市場派也跟進去了對不對
主力可能是外資投信
你看這邊主力賣超
關鍵已經在收了
偷偷收
先觀察對不對
看這裡主力開始往上了
這邊主力開始大買了
其實我們就應該動作了
你在這裡買的時候180附近而已
你雖然不會買到最低點174
沒差多少嗎
沒差啦 18017就差6塊
而且重點是買在1710要等很久
對 要等很久
你不如買在主力買的時候
哇 你進場了 他就開始走囉
今天就一根大紅K囉
對 買股票當然希望買了馬上動啊
現代人超沒耐心
像我就是買了沒動賣掉
不想講了
我最近有一檔股票賣掉隔天漲6%
今天又漲5%
那還可惜啊
那這個假如你想要
做空一些股票避險的話
對
避險因為太多多單了嘛
偶爾要些空單避險
對
那像這個如虹啊
它關鍵分點各位看一下
主力買的時候關鍵分點在到貨喔
對
因為關鍵分點要在高檔到的比較開心
其實剛剛我們有看到
它賣其實會賣比較快
對
買是慢慢收
賣看起來像瀑布一樣
都賣滿快
你看到這個大漲趕快到啊
因為他們可能知道後面的營收狀況嘛
溜要快點溜啦
他們到的時候
其實你的多單還不用出啦
你要等到什麼時候
你要等到這條主力這條線
主力也轉賣囉
主力轉賣的時候
你可以進場把你的多單賣掉
或者是你可以小小的空它
也可以啦
不過我覺得這跟談戀愛
真的很像嘛
就是你要交往前
你會Cook一段時間
讓你的感情升溫
但是分手就趕快好不好
快點
快閃
沒錯
好
那我們長期呢
我們研究關鍵分點
各位看一下
11月8號寫的
主頭買
還記得嗎
紅塑大漲
關鍵買一堆大漲
太多了
寫不完
什麼叫一堆大漲
沒有股票叫一堆
就是很多股票
我們在影音中有講
但是我們標題寫不上
寫不下去了
黃關鍵漲停
高漲出貨股一堆大跌
主頭買關鍵買一堆大漲即漲停
申報轉爛股
預頂跌停
對
9月11號關鍵買
集盛大涨 财新涨停
这些你看之前
关键分点天天卖
康有跌停
康有是我们最先
对啊我们都看得出来
最先揭露的都还没有出事
我们就先提醒了
我们都还不怕人家
黑道来追杀我们
我们就先讲了
好可怕
都跑了
老板都跑了
老板已经没有时间雇我们了
对啊那这些呢
我都会在我的教育笔记本
全任小哥教育笔记本
交给各位
好
所以呢赵华学了
股市非常多的技巧
什麼東西最難
其實籌碼叫做真金白銀
會拿真金白銀來把籌碼的線做出來的話
它是最難懂
可是它也是最容易準確度最高的啦
真的
所以不要靠自己撈啦
有一個軟體真的是比較方便
沒有軟體真的做不到啊
沒錯
所以今天呢
有沒有今天拿到了耶誕禮物
你們也拿到了小哥的耶誕禮物喔
雖然我們會講說
其實現在我們的政府有很多得正
我們以前呢
撈籌碼超級麻煩
你可以去問老一輩的
都要去圖書館翻喔
政府有地方放籌碼資料的
每天寄每天寄
然後畫Excel什麼的
現在其實不用喔
現在科技很發達嘛
軟體也做得很好
所以呢有時候不常知啊
工具
你一定要有工具喔
工具幫你省非常多時間
你會更多時間去研究啊
到底有哪些籌碼是好
哪些籌碼不好
要是你光是自己在那邊畫圖喔
你不用研究了啦
說真的
每天時間都消耗掉了
所以呢今天小哥來介紹
他每天都在用的籌碼K喔
那趙華也是喔
我每天都在用小哥
所以希望大家呢 好不好 這套軟體很值得
如果你研究籌碼 相信小哥每次秀的最大單你都很羨慕的話
趕快加入喔
那今天的理財答案秀 歌有頭必爆就到這邊了
我們下次再見了 掰掰
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive